якщо з першого століття при перекриваються
кордоні Європи це напевно важко
перебільшувати і звичайно ж це не
стосується скажімо територій нато або
євросоюзу і якось впевнений до цього не
знайде але все одно ось сама то це
нестабільність, недоведеність скажемо так
безкарність цих дій це
звичайно не нормально, оскільки в майбутньому
можуть бути й інші президенти, так як і
були в минулому до речі якщо згадати
війну на південному кавказі 8 8 роки
після nexia частини території
грузії можна перераховувати та перераховувати
бажання мати добрі стосунки воно
зрозуміло але якщо
якщо будуть з іншого боку
керуватися не міжнародним
правом з ніби винайденими правилами
самих ось як іноді буває специфіка
така буває у Росії їсти такий
нюанс
Треба визнати, що все керівництво з
якимось одними скажемо законами та якось
такі специфічні правила так от якщо
буде компроміси у цьому плані там ми
матимемо більше проблем не тільки
крим не тільки не тільки скажемо осетії та
абхазії
але придністров'я ще на вас чекає в черзі
або інші якісь навіть географічно і
інші моменти ну по перше тут не
так легко все зняти, оскільки не тільки
що тато продовжено на рік та й тонн
там є деякі ти підтримкою з
конгресу
ми тоді відійшли б це критеріїв якось
яких домовилися, оскільки причин
притчі причини з яких введено
санкції вони не зняті якщо ми не знімемо
причини а знімемо санкції так ми тоді
відступаємо по суті справи або
за чекаємо зелене світло на те, що щось
робиться і тоді буде дійсно
ситуації некерованою великим провалом
та політики ціннісних орієнтацій якщо
так сталося б